well good evening members welcome to
this
full committee meeting
uh officers and those members of the
republic that are joining us on youtube
[Music]
first item on the agenda is apologies
for absence
thank you chair
council craigie
councillor wright councillor watson
councillor heckle councilman mcgoff
councillor mountain
councillor
seems to be very nice it sounds like
it's going to be a really swift meeting
page by page
starting on page four
five
six
seven
sure
thanks brandon
to jeffrey cox under the nhs there was a
lad
chair there's a letter response from
jeffrey cox can you speak to them
um
we
[Music]
so favorite be sure
just in case anyone
[Music]
against your obsessions
item three public contributions there
are no
public questions to speak
item four declarations of interest and
you won't know the store there if
there's any items on the agenda please
raise them there could be time
item five agreement of the agenda
between items for one and two or arnold
park two items
item six to consider correspondence put
forward by the chair
i have a particular
item seven to answer questions under
procedure rule a9 no questions have been
submitted
i have tonight petitions
there are no petitions received
so bring themselves roughly to item nine
uh local catholic tax support abandoned
income schemes as pages eight to twelve
in your agenda and david hayes the
section 151 officer will present
counselors you don't know the colleague
on the left is john wells she's head of
the rebs and ben's service so at the end
of the presentation if there's any
questions of course joel will be the
fans of our knowledge
okay
um
bob first off before we're going to the
proposal for local council transport
might be wise just to give a little bit
of background so prior to 2013 council
success tolerance were tasked with
administering a system of council tax
benefits on behalf of the dwp
in essence for every one pound the
council did not collect because of the
awarded council tax benefit the council
was reimbursed one pound by the dwp
there was no differential between
pensioners working age claimants on low
income
however 2013 central government mandated
that councils introduced a system of
local council tax support and the key
points to note being
at the start
point for its funding for local council
tax support central women took the
existing expenditure on council tax
benefit and then cut it by ten percent
then central government dictates that
pensioners could be no worse off and as
pensioners represent fifty percent of
the claim and council anymore actually
then in the first instance it's
effectively a twenty percent cut in
funding the funding for local council
tax report was then allocated to develop
in relative percentage of the council
tax retained by the various preceptors
and in the first year we actually had a
separate grant for local council tax
support separately identifiable in
social years the local countertops are
programmed incorporated into council
general grant funding which has then
been subject to
further clubs in subsequent years that's
life based on
our attempting to chart
uh hopefully is behind me
so you start off with the chat the
left-hand bar the council tax benefit in
blue
then they do a 10 cut but then because
we have to protect the pensioners
effectively that was another ten percent
cut
and then that funding that's left over
was distributed by you know once the
precepts obviously the main distribution
went to devon county council as they are
the biggest um take of the council tax
and the police ourselves fire town house
councils
and as i've said in some certain years
that grant funding you can see was
incorporated with local authorities
general grant settlement so i'm trying
to get to long convoluted introduction
isn't saying to all intents and purposes
local council tax support is funded from
tolerance's own resources the council
tactic collects the retained business
rates fees and charges etc
next five weeks
[Music]
so now i'm just going to move on to
talking about the actual lawful council
[Music]
ideally the council's local council tax
function should have been reviewed on a
regular basis a previous call to men's
scheme in 2016 was rejected by members
the impact on the pandemic on the
workload of the reps and benefits scenes
as delayed the subsequent review of this
scheme
so
you've got the report but what's being
proposed we're providing an interruption
income banded scheme where depending on
the income of working age claims they're
placing one of four bands and will
receive support of up to 75 percent 50
20 10 or 10 percent of their council tax
liability
this is a basic principle that's been
adopted by many councils across the
country we're also for the ease of
administration proposing to remove the
non-dependent deduction the member's not
aware what that is and non-independent
was somebody perhaps who's who lives in
the house of their mother who's perhaps
on local councils at support but they're
in full-time employment and at the
moment they get less local council tax
support because they've got a
non-dependent in full employment and
they've expected that that doesn't
essentially make a contribution to the
council that so what we're proposing is
that actually gets removed by
administrative ease
we've retained the van d limit and the 6
000 capital amount of the current scheme
i would introduce a minimum income floor
for self-employed people in line with
the universal credit which essentially
is 35 hours time the national minimum
living wage
so what the advantage of the scheme that
we're proposing
we've got an income banded discounting
based on setbands and income will help
to contain administration costs as we
reduce if we reduce the number of times
we need to reassess people's claims
it'll be simpler for customers to
understand and easy for them to budget
as they'll have a significant reduction
in the number of bills going this
particularly affects people who work and
their wages change
and removing the non-dependent judgment
also reduces the administrative burden
and also in line with the self-employed
um
minimum floor facility that aligns with
current universal credit regulations
apology is a bit of a boring slide
there
so what the key plan is this the scheme
that would propose was modeled by
experts in the field called policy and
practice on behalf of the council
and the key findings are the scheme is
projected to be essentially cost neutral
cost of we're projecting 18 000 pounds
well that's spread across all the
preceptors so our share of that is on
just over one thousand pounds
there are certain 1 650 work days claims
for local council tax support only two
households would lose support completely
85 of the working age claims would
receive 75 support towards their counter
tax liability
101 households would see there was
support reduced by over 5 pounds a week
255 households have gained more than
five pounds a week and those losing are
proudly primarily self-employed on
legacy benefits
and i think the tables in the report are
not potent to go through the temple it
just shows the bands and the money that
people can earn when they fall into the
different backs
so
then we're trying to do that is show a
visual
so at the bottom you see a roller
coaster roller coaster supposed to
represent people's earnings going up and
down
so long as they stay within the band we
wouldn't need to reassess them for local
council test support it's only when
they're earning to go above the band
which is the blue line
that we would need to do a reassessment
so we'll certainly cut down on the
administration within the local council
tax support team
so
just there there's a chart
so it shows that 85 of people will be in
band one the most generous
and then as you can see bands two three
and four the negligible numbers and they
are some lonely eluded numbers who would
relatively lose more than five pounds i
mean i'd probably say dark
looking for confirmation from anybody
okay and on the right hand side those
who gain more than 500 the yellow bar so
it's clear that the vast majority of our
client claiming group would be in band
one which is the most generous
right so conclusion the scheme is
simpler for our residents and it's also
simpler for ourselves as the council to
administer
given the recruitment and retention
difficulties being faced by the council
anything produces the administrative
burden upon the council is welcome
just to give some context currently the
council receives 20
800 electronic notifications of changes
from universal credit regarding change
in universal credit awards these loan
certifications have to be considered by
benefit officers amendments to local
council tax support may ie rebuildings
for reference there are full-time four
full-time equivalent benefits successes
in the establishment the introduction of
band is given dramatically reduced
number awards that need to be amended
and rebuilt
that time when council budgets have
faced an exceptional prostitute to high
protect levels of inflation improving
that the proposed scheme does not
increase the cost of local council tax
support to the council as i said before
it is broadly cost neutral
so
what are the next steps well we're here
tonight
hoping to see your call council through
the post scheme
then we'll have to go after consultation
which reports in 12 weeks and this will
involve parish councils the preceptors
other partners such as the cab mail shop
and obviously a comm strategy
we'll report back to fall council with
the result of the consolation
consultation a senior involved council's
formal approval policy
there will have to be training for staff
implementation in conjunction with
capital capital r software providers for
reps and event services and all this
needs to be in place before the end of
january 2023 because of the needs of
annual billing so really we need
approval tonight
it just seems a long way away january
2025 when you work backwards
with the timetable of consultation that
we need and also the training and the
liaison with the
software provider we really could do
with um
your approval tonight or otherwise
this juncture just let's hand over to
councillor newton
david thank you for that presentation as
a lead member for this area i'd just
like to
conclude this bit of work is long
overdue
council asked for it some time ago
kobe got in the way and then the demands
on the staff have also made it difficult
there's been a lot of work in this
especially with all the modeling
required externally and independent um
uh consultation uh
this
i mean it says it on the tin
this will make it easier and more
understandable for the claimant it will
also lead to greater continuity for the
claimant because he won't be switched on
and off off and off every time the
income goes up and down
likewise for the administration
there will be less cases to look at and
it will be easier to do and therefore
all round it makes sense there are some
who will
want to see a higher figure than the 75
well 75
across the board puts us roughly where
we are at the moment on the old system
in terms of the level of payment and
anyway it is a question of affordability
and at the moment we just could not
afford more anyway uh so um
i
fully commend two councillors this work
that's being done um and uh
i will when it comes around to it
propose the um that we
recommend or go ahead with the
consultation
thank you guys
any questions from countries
yeah it was a nitpicking question really
on page 11 above the word invocations
we're talking about the software uh
survivor there's an annual subscription
of
475 pounds
access to local council tech support
software's about the academy suite of
programs for web's events
the reality is you have to
you need a software to administer rev's
events and to a large extent there's two
players in the market one of them's
capital one of them
corrected joe with exchange is a company
called northgate and a few council use
systems that they may have developed in
the past
we're limited on choice of who we go
with
that's the simple truth for them
all the hands what happened at the same
time
that's a panicking you caught my eye
first well thank you chair um thank you
for your report a very good report very
good reading as well
i can fully support everything apart
from the first line
because i think we need a consultation
and feedback and i tell you so why
the whole picture since council tax
became localized in 2013
is the pension age for for particularly
females have gone up from 60 now to 66
and there's been a change that one of a
couple was a working age they both
qualified for pension credit or is this
the reverse snow of the situation as
well and what i'm really concerned about
under universal credit
is that um the way that the uh uh
calculation is made
there's 63 percent of the remember where
the income is considered over a certain
above point so therefore those in work
tend to gain better than those naught
and i see you're going to constant
consult with citizens of ice bureau i'm
lead member that works with citizens of
vice bureau i would like to see devon
karen association involved because one
of the crisis we're now facing in this
country go back eight years a
six-year-old female could care for their
parent come out of hospital because they
could immediately go on to um state
retirement pension if they qualify for
state retirement pension uh from that
point of view they become a carer now
they get caught only on the 75 percent
though of what you're alone under the
universal credit levels of pension
credit their classes working age
effectively and this has caused a huge
problem
for releasing people from hospital
because working uh women particularly
women and uh of 60 to 65 have to
continue with employment because they
cannot give up the time now to go and
care and that's why we're seeing
ambulances outside hospitals and this is
not very well thought forward from that
point of view great if you're in work
ready for yourself employed but not good
if you are a carer
i would like carers to be consulted if
you can possibly i fully support what
you've done don't get me i'm not against
it but i cannot give approval tonight
until we consider the weakest of working
age in our society thank you chair
thank you managing
did you have your hand up tonight
remind me
why the council checked this out in
2016.
what's different between this scheme and
what was just that in 2016
particularly bearing in mind in 2016 it
was a conservative controlled council
and it's now recommended by the
conservatives
thank you jesus
we do have an exceptional hardship fund
where we have 127 000 so people could
make a claim against that
i think it's unfair to pop on the
council changes in central government
legislation and rising pension credit
that's not something we're in control of
and when you say today what we're asking
for today is approval for this scheme to
go after consultation and then when we
come back we'll give you the results of
the consultation
you were asking about that
search here on that first bullet point
full council approval of proposed scheme
we're proposing that we accept the
scheme and that's the very wording that
i just cannot accept
contributions so if i may interject that
the wording on that screen is not
actually the same as the wording on the
paper that we are considering
the authority is the paper that we are
considering
and the paper that we're considering to
members authorized officers to begin a
formal consultation on the proposed
amendments to the lcts scheme as
detailed and that full council approves
in principle
the suggested amendments to the ltsc so
they're talking about in principle but
it's still open to change because it's
proposed that's too blunt it doesn't
actually reflect exactly what's being
said in the paperwork thank you for your
explanation remember thank you
there were several other hands
kneeling did you have your hand up yes
okay
why is it such a long period of
consultation in 12 weeks
[Music]
within the revenues and benefits um
for the
main thing that people say is for 12
weeks minimum consultation because the
scheme
as approved or not is subject to
potentially going to court so
because of the challenges that the
public or any organization can come up
against your scheme you have to have a
decent consultation period
any other questions
2016 i started work in june 2016 with
torres district council it's not vivid
in my memory the reasons for its uh
rejection by memphis i'm sorry i can't
help any further
it looks like um
[Music]
um
the area that we're in because it's
seasonal unemployment and a lot of
caring responsibilities so we have a lot
of care but there are a lot of zero hour
contracts so because people's earnings
do fluctuate
having a banded scheme means that people
will know how much they can earn before
they can get into the next band it's to
bring us in line with the universal
credit as well
think of that because
it does seem that
this government's
acceptance of zero
contracts does seem to lead to more work
from the torres district council and
isn't it about time we actually started
approaching our mp and saying look can
we sort out these zero-hour projects and
i know people are wrong
and they're earning structure wildly
out any domestic economy because of that
and here we are we are creative we've
got more work to do because of that as
well and it does seem really unfair
that central government will just allow
this to happen we are actually
subsidising private companies
[Music]
area
is and torbay that don't have an
incompetent scheme at the moment
special halton you're in my blind spot
here
i do apologize
um
could you go on to the next slide a
moment please now it might be the fact
that
i'm sitting a long way away
but
70 percent
and 40 percent
and 20
and 10
can we
it's just a
matter
of it doesn't work
before
[Laughter]
75
is the maximum award that somebody can
have so the big bar chart is that the
vast majority of people will get 75 of
help towards uh a smaller number of
people will get 40 percent help towards
their council tax and a smaller
proportion of people will get
20 percent of help towards the council
time so those figures should never
happen to 100
so the numbers so 75 percent of the
amount of reward they can get towards
their council tax they'll be expected to
pay 25 their council tax
i've obviously not explained that
completely to councils of satisfaction
[Music]
it as round
i'm having trouble i can't get logged on
tonight i think i personally just
returned
thank you
apologies for the officers taking
advantage of the chief executive being
away in a sport as well
[Music]
one minute you're owning something and
then all of a sudden you're over a
threshold could you how are you how are
people expected to know that is that in
their p60s is it reviewed yearly or are
they expected to report to you when
they're hours left they can go
yeah the duty is always on the customer
to advise the benefits of any change in
circumstance however if somebody's
embassy of universal credit we get the
automation and the notifications that
come through
if somebody's
earning a certain amount of money we do
have access to
um hmrc records
so we do have a variety of means of
getting that information but at the end
of the day is up to the individual
customer to advisors of the change
however
on
one of the slides for sure there's 20
800 notifications that we receive from
universal credit about people's earnings
no i don't believe no if they're on
universal credit we'll get some
notifications from the universal credit
they've got a different award with
universal credit but the oldness is on
the person to tell us
[Music]
[Music]
well that's the same as it is now under
the existing scheme
right
[Music]
i understand you're in contact with the
dwp why can't the dwp communicate with
you when there's a change in the
universal credit so that somebody
doesn't face an overpayment why can't
that take place
as i've said we do get the notification
from the department for working pensions
but in the legislation is the illnesses
on the customer to provide the
information to us but we do get
notifications that come through which is
the
nylon 21 000 notifications that we get
through all you have to remember
is that because universal credit is a
monthly payment if somebody's wages
fluctuate during that period we get
notifications
each time we have that we have to
process somebody's claim which means
then they get a letter from us they also
get a new bill and as the council
bristol was saying it makes it very very
difficult in the scheme that we have at
the moment for people to think but yeah
we're following against you am i sorry
that you will move on and get home
before it gets too hot
i think we've already passed that one
right okay
it puts us in the disposition because we
know when somebody's receiving
overpayment when they do not realize it
and sometimes yes there is fraud i
accept there is fraud and i don't agree
with anybody who defaults the system
but sometimes people come home from
university and then become a
non-dependent that's been taken away i
congratulate you for that but there's
lots of other little proposal areas
where things change that the recipient
of uh crowds attacks isn't aware of that
i hope it's not used as a stick
to then get repayments over the lincoln
family because they fail to notify you
when you're already normally answered
question
there will be less notifications that
they will need to advise themselves at
the moment they have to tell us about
everything this income-bounded scheme is
based purely on somebody's wages
i
your mind with the hand up first
it's quite small actually um
when you receive benefits you're
constantly watching them because you
don't want to receive an open payment
because you've got to pay it back
and that is in your mind all the time
i must be getting close to the threshold
online and calculate it you can add it
at all on the website
well clearly it is a somewhat
complicated and slightly flawed system
but it's what we've got um because of
leather i think
hopefully it comes together with the
last word almost
thank you chair well
you know interesting listen to all the
comments but
i was on
foreign councillor pennington's
uh first
view of this
and i'm going to support this providing
that this in principle support this
thing
is that and then it will come back
before it's implemented
it'll come back after a confrontation
period
for us to then look at the concentration
responses and then decide definitely
that is exactly the position we'll come
back again for full ratification david
is that right
yes i believe that's in the
recommendations
okay i hate confrontations that happen
after people have discounted them
i say this is in principle
at the moment so it's been proposed by
councillor newton
seconded by coach mclaren
and
support
on those again
[Music]
and abstentions
thank you
2141 again
okay moving on to item 10 is the shared
prosperity for the submission
[Music]
delegated again
[Music]
over eucharist
[Music]
[Music]
so
the sharepoint charity fund was
announced in lebanon white paper and it
has long been billed as the replacement
source of funding for european funds uh
when those dropped away and
i think those of us who've been involved
in the process of the share prosperity
fund without saying we really do wish
that was the case
it does have uh four main themes those
are boosting productivity pay jobs and
living standards a growing private
sector i think that is directly relevant
in this conversation following on from
the previous point uh and around joe's
concern announcements and cancer's
concerns around zero hours contracts for
example making sure that in this area we
move beyond
the issues of constantly seasonal
seasonal
low level
low wage low skill insurance
this is around spreading opportunities
and improving public services
but also about restoring a sense of
community local pride private belonging
as well as empowering local leaders
communities
in the next five months
crucially
what all of the government's input and
advice on a series of webinars and
consonants of information is emphasizing
that the shared prosperity fund is not
about effectively covering over cracks
this is about creating true growth
opportunities and seizing of any
opportunities within the local economy
where they're there to be maximized
and also
given the size of funds available
it should be used again appropriately to
access leverage for additional
investment rather than looking to do
everything just through the shared
prosperity fund in itself
the three things which have been uh
established by those in communities in
place
supporting local businesses and from 24
to 25 people and skills
which is the official kind of
threshold when european fans will be
chopping
the shared prosperity fund um
has 2.6 billion pounds potential from
terms of 225.
and torres unfortunately only has 1
million pounds of that
[Music]
which is really not very much money to
create
the true impacts that we would like to
be able to create
but what that does mean is we need to be
as creative and as targeted as possible
rather than necessarily
[Music]
next time
the shared prosperity fund
was
kind to the
guidance that was issued
demanded that
local authorities
utilize a local partnership group
uh
to help drive the development of the
investment plan that we have to submit
in north devon this role was sold by the
new endeavor futures and the
organization has been created with key
stakeholders from across the area
following um uh
initial main boards inputs sub-group
meetings were then organized
under the themes listed
beyond
that think it's fairly safe to say that
my inbox has been flooded with uh
inquiries from organizations from
across northern devon devon and
nationally wanting a slightest
authority's shared prosperity fund and
however we've very much taken
the line of working
hand and blood with north korean council
to make sure that again
where we are
reaching these topics that we can
maximize our shared
investments into changing local gain
and i'm aware that in the reports that
went out to members there wasn't much
detail in terms of the projects that
were being proposed um for which i
apologize uh the reports for both this
and the culture strategy had to be
submitted uh before we finished the um
leveling up bid
it's growing government timetables and
not making things particularly easy
however we felt it was very important to
make sure that our initial thinking is
outlined to members for feedback
the first thing that i mentioned was
that communities in place
some of the
teams that have come back
ideas and that align with current work
strands
are that
we
for e1
which come back as a strong theme and
given the importance of town centres
through our communities
explore opportunities around uh pilot
schemes for vacant units
working with an organization in gymnasts
who are sort of leading nationally on
that and making templates and toolkits
available to a range of businesses
to enable those pop-ups and meanwhile
users have long abandoned
vacant
empty units and towns
and potentially funds allowing um some
investment in small level beautification
of those town centers to make more
appealing places and
one of the themes that has come through
on a number of occasions is that of uh
social behavior in towns and making sure
that our communities do feel safe and so
potentially providing some small level
match funding towards uh schemes such as
the successful street margins that were
rolled out last year in business
in terms of e6
next um
strategy that will truly mean nothing at
all unless we're actually in a position
to have capacity to deliver a
performance
another cultural strategy also helps
underpin
the attractiveness of torridge as a
place for future business opening and
that loops backgrounds to where i was
with the last time around the staff was
all clean management innovation sector
and making sure that torres is basically
right for future investments and job
creation
and then them uh around some work around
pilots supporting the work of the actors
again
that links up to
tourism opportunities as well as just uh
finally our own communities are based
looking at
relevant opportunities around
disability studies
we know that we are living through a
housing crisis so making sure that we do
have some money available
to support
those firm investigations that are just
taking out innovates within
housing
that looks like this
the supportive business
thing because sometimes
that's nice and
the network is really is about how over
the next three years we've grown the
maritime sector
but also how we grow connected
uh sectors and make sure that when we
open the door actually maritime
innovation center
that we have pipeline businesses ready
to move in and then we can maximize the
figures and the impacts of that uh
i searched as proposals to
include our investment plan uh
specialist marine development officer
who was the
familiar walking in the
closed power and into boardrooms as well
as getting kind of sleeves rolled up and
working with various different engineers
to make sure that the
world of capital is out there and with a
strong enough position to secure
additional funding and projects through
that center
but at the same time making sure that we
are rolling out business support
programs
and
grant schemes to be able to support
those businesses necessarily purely
within maritime
having one specialist and
to support our local families
[Music]
sorry question like before you just go
on
home
brendan is waving his heart in front of
him i think he's got something
i'll just put him up
here
okay
quite fortunately
[Music]
[Music]
we can support um
further
measures in particular following on from
the community funds where they did
secure last year the largest net zero in
the country
and the community fund was on the scene
as a route
to learning and then to delivery through
the shared prosperity fund unfortunately
torrey secured nearly 3 million pounds
in
the community fund
to prepare for the ship was verified we
now only have one million to spend
over three years
[Music]
uh thanks john
uh even the skills team it's far harder
to find out this point getting the facts
that actually we're talking about
basically two and a half years time
and we know that the economy is changing
dramatically and has changed from that
region of course the last few years
um kind of thinking the signing funds
for future uh employment support
um
but we're discussing the therapist as
the partners to make sure that we get
that
which brings us to the recommendations
and including the reports
for
[Music]
[Music]
um
going to kick this off before i come to
council renters
and this 1 million pound allocation that
we've got from
the government then do we know
the amounts that other local authorities
have actually been awarded and is once
again encouraged getting the smaller
slice of the cake
yes yes
so
how much smaller is it
so
it depends on the different areas
understanding
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well
i've said this before i mean
if
education in charge education devon has
always
received you know
a really
major share of what the
education funding should be
we always get the short end of the stick
and i think you know we i know we've
when i was involved with college we've
written the jeffrey courts and various
other ministers you know complaining
about this but um
well it just seems to me that uh once
again
because of where we are we are
we get shortchanged
i'm sure casual president is probably
going to say something like this
um
uh
[Music]
support
[Music]
needs
lots of courses
for skills and training
disappeared
themselves
it's just we wouldn't be able to
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
there why was that particularly kicked
on
that was just taken from the
uh
the tourist profile where it contains
the list of um
uh in season multiple deprivation and
sort of caught up broken down into uh so
as that was in the lower quartile uh
absolutely i think in the list by the
next student
sorry the presentation
was almost embarrassing
we'll just is on the need for anyone to
stand when we're speaking all right
i do apologize
[Music]
because if you look at torridge
separately from the rest of everyone
we're far poorer than cornwall yet we're
always lucked in with south hands and
exeter we've always lost there
always but i've got three questions um
firstly
we've got a million pound in three years
how much did we get from the eu
that's the first
uh question because i seem to remember
when i asked this question before
the answer was we actually got more
leaving the eu made it poorer
secondly who represents torridge on the
north heaven futures board which i must
admit i hadn't heard of before it hadn't
really swung into my
uh ideas but
and thirdly
there i see devon county if you've gone
with them they wanted a quarter of the
money for admin
it's going to go through north 10 plus
do you know how much north devon plus
we're going to take
and could i just make one other point i
said it is in here that um
we are actually looking at startups and
can i make a plea that we actually
invest in some of our startups
because
i've i've been invested well i've been
investing the british trust money in
startups for 18 years now
and some of the ideas i get presented
with are fantastic
they are really invasive
and yet the one problem with this area
because people on their wages they
haven't got the cash to start up
and we're in this sort of catch-22
situation and yet
you know not everyone's going to succeed
we know that but i would like this to
actually invest in some of these
startups because
um
my best start up ever now employs 45
people
and quite a few of my startups are in
cats down
units now
and it's got to come from somewhere that
money and i would make a clear
good anyway sorry you've probably
forgotten three questions i was about to
start out and say apologies i've
measurably failed to retain kind of most
of those and
how much did you get from the year
so
yes
tourist directly does not receive
something from the moment
however
as i mentioned we've been receiving
enquiries from various different and
regional and national partners and many
of them were really operational against
the likes of general county the rights
of
petroc even as part of the world of
pensions a number of their schemes are
european tournament and all of those
will drop away um
so
i think in years three there will be a
considerable loss of investments in
positions
we
[Music]
thank you and uh
how much we're going to lose in
admission plus
i can't remember
[Music]
i don't know the exact percentage but
the reason for the recommendation was uh
that we'd looked into proposals it was
considerably less and so it won't be
anything like that uh i can bring it
back as an action point for a future or
circulate the
proposal percentage if you wanted to
probably email it yeah i'm happy to do
that
chair i think the other thing to point
out and chris is chris has done a a good
job presenting something that's quite
complex there i think there was a lot of
rhetoric when this fund was talked about
but it was going to be the replacement
for european funding everywhere it
hasn't turned out to be that it doesn't
get close to being that
the leader program that we used to run
through north devon plus was more
funding allocation than this whole
prosperity fund allocation is to give
you some context
and so what the thematic approach that's
been selected does is tries to give you
uh some thinking of where we think
you're going to get the best thank you
about with what isn't enough money we
had 100 times that we could put it to
good use but it's trying to use that
million pounds to get the most out of
work through our economy that's the
thematic approach uh suggested to you
but don't just come back on that because
i think that's a very good point but i
will reiterate what i've said that
i'd rather it went direct to businesses
rather than on admin and you know all
the usual stuff we get the business
expertise and so on and you think
actually i'd rather spend on real jobs
all right did
did i miss someone this time
did you ever have earlier no
no i'm not kidding
uh because you're never had his hand on
first no come on
[Music]
there are 20 interventions here that
will be the three areas
united spreading the knowledge far to
incentives
and i think it should have been on
perhaps three or four main
interventions and that should be
businesses
predominantly the business
but over three years and running again
it's just disappearing
[Music]
20 interventions far too much
so what do you want to do so yeah i can
respond to that part i mean i'm not
going to disagree with you catching a
letter in touch
i think what we've we've proposed
and i i yeah you are absolutely right
and i'm never going to stop giving
when
what we're proposing here is you might
think spreading it thin we're looking
for leverage so i suppose it's using
what is a little bit of fun to try and
learn from more um in from elsewhere
leave a more growth and so you know i
think if you have more it would be
fantastic take your point about
targeting it i think we'll have to
refine what we've got i think chris
might want to add um yeah
one question and yeah just really just
say uh
i think the the crucial thing is that
although there's a number of the
interventions ticked it's because we
have to take them if our intentions kind
of cross over on that field i think when
you're talking about kind of
business support that then leads to kind
of grant programs that ends up taking a
few different interventions
which rapidly started
special management
sorry sorry
and say
my worry is that this money all three
years
will be threatened away on lots of these
things that i can't even understand
what the interventions actually are it
fitted away and the government had
turned around and said well it did give
you a million
chris mentioned earlier that um you know
one of the things this could be used to
support is the
state marshals scheme
speaking personally in believing in west
develop that scheme has been an absolute
boon to local businesses and it
certainly makes the public feel so much
safer when they have a couple of uniform
personnel walking around the town um
the amount of people that have
expressed their disappointment that the
scheme hasn't been rolled out this year
i've asked forward but there's no money
available for torres to actually um you
know do this at the moment so
if this is
if it can if this scheme can help then
you know it's it's a good thing council
money first and then we'll come up
[Music]
can i just check that this is the only
grant scheme that
woody's department is investigating
because i think there's another one
thing
yeah no
um jan williams team are looking at
other grants as well specifically the
street marshalling right i thought that
was so there may be other opportunities
and i'm doing our best
casual
you know who i am
[Music]
[Music]
from the chair that we accept this
have a second at least
[Music]
all in favor be sure
can i just ask after this three years
can the council have a report on where
the money was spent
yes
authority to do um we'll we'll we can
circulate that information so somebody
else inputs on that that's all
okay i can move them on there till 11 on
the agenda leisure business plan update
pages 22-25
and
[Music]
david hayes is going to present the
report
[Music]
[Music]
thank you sean thank you thank you
council hudson
so
when setting the budget for 2023 for
leisure the council was not in receipt
of all the necessary information
we didn't know the membership numbers we
didn't really know the staffing numbers
that were required we were out to tender
for the back office cost that we were
servicing what was provided
we only had 16 tens over cost
and we had limited information regarding
the utility
consequently
requested a report was produced after
three months to validate the assumptions
made with the budget set for leisure so
this is a report back after the first
three months operation for that staff
police tom
so when we set the leisure budget
for the current financial year 2022-23
we assumed the council would have to
support active
national activities by mistake active
tolerance to the value of 677
000 pounds a year
and the top
little chart is that table
and essentially the projected cost for
leisure for the financial 2022-23
are currently within budgetary
expectations i.e legends currently
projected to cost 20 000 pounds over and
above the 677 000 currently event
the forecast budget performance for our
targets there's a modest growth in
income over the remainder of the
financial year primarily from increased
swimming lessons next time
so however i really kind of maybe want
to gather
members attention really looking forward
rather than the first three months that
we've gone through this year
as everybody's aware
inflation is at historic highs and not
seen these levels of inflation probably
since the mid 70s
uh utility pressures
currently active torridge are benefited
from accessing tourist councils
pre-purchased gas and electricity
however this deal ends in october 2022
at which point the gases will rise by
146 and 82
respectively
the minimum living wage is currently
9.50 an hour leisure assistance at
active turrets are on twenty thousand
pound year for forty hour a week which
equates to nine pound fifty nine per
hour
the minimum living wage is expected to
be updated by inflation which is
just about 10
in the autumn coming into effect from
the first of april 2023
by which by the minimum living wage will
be in the region 10 pound 45 per hour
consequently there will be inflationary
pressure on the pay bill for access we
cannot pay below the minimum living wage
but they'll option to consider it will
the cost of living crisis lead to some
people prior prioritizing their
discretionary spend
gym memberships
next slide please tom
[Music]
the information's in the report is only
a free major approach i happen to take
any questions at this juncture
special laws
in real terms
[Music]
we're already
meeting these costs because they're on
fuel they're not actually on gas
and when you see those prices from
fostering so you've got remember that's
the increase to the pre-purchase price
that the council entered into about
three years ago
so it's not just this year's invasion
probably over the years inflation built
in but probably in the region of 80 to
90 000 pounds
today so can i just pick you up ask you
to clarify
you've given what you've called a
leisure business plan update
in fact the
um the meeting in in december last year
our recommendations um
the members charge active torrid with
reporting back by the end of june with
an updated base cost model that's what
you've just given i think essentially
what i'm saying is the
fortuitously the budget opportunities
that the budgets we set essentially are
valid for this year coming back in the
september october probably in october
now will actually be a more substantial
report saying well how do we meet the
challenges going forward absolutely
because the board of active torridge the
board of active torridge
is charged with reporting back to us
in sep by the end of september
with an updated business plan that's not
just
bringing the figures up to
the
and the
when we know what things are going to
cost that's actually going to confirm
how they're going to actually conduct
business and conduct business going
forward so it's something much more
wider and it is actually the board who
are tasked to report to us that is from
what we we gave in yeah
yeah i just wanted to update members
that there's actually a gender item for
next week's board uh no we have the next
activator board meeting this draft
business plan agenda and just because of
committee dates it'll actually the
october committee that it comes back to
could i just follow up with and ask that
we are not asked to
that presentation to us
on the revised business plan with the
different options which were laid out in
in december last year that we said they
were to come forward with
that that is actually presented to us
after the budget working group has
presented because until we know
the conclusions of the budget working
group which we've then
discussed and thought about and really
understand how much money we have got or
not got we cannot make a decision
on uh funding
of a major major funder like this so
we've got to get the the horse before
the car surely it's fine so to be clear
on what activators will be presented
back they won't be
presenting you with their an options
analysis for what you apply funding to
we've agreed the funding and so what
they'll be saying is this is what we're
going to do with your money that's what
the business plan will be
with options to reduce the net cost to
the council to the current budget
current budget plus 25 current budget
plus 50 those are options which active
torrid have been tasked to come back to
us with
that's the case apparently kenzie jones
thank you an interesting report it was
good to see that
it seems like the um facilities are able
to start with something like guys a
thousand pounds left less than was
initially budgeted for because i know
sometimes when we saw
but when we get more information on the
finances council newton
has already mentioned can we have that
again broken down
into the three sites so we can see how
all three
are operating independently
to make any decisions that need to be
made thank you yeah the issue um we will
do that the reason i was tempted to
actually show the breakdown by the free
stats issue i have is the separation of
costs which don't organically fall on
any one side so matt is the manager
that's an easy one you can just do that
on the left side there's other
without some issues really capturing
them because of that so i did want to
um present information and start
different sites when i wasn't sure i had
all the costs allocated on a fair and
equal basis
[Music]
my understanding of causing
the environment for this
is that is that something that's
factored into this
um to some extent because we'd actually
could you there would be due a
what's the expression um
loss of income claim so from the active
torridge's perspective they would be
compensated by that
i mean it's not been a natural thing
because um torringtonville hasn't been
opened for the entirety since the 1st of
april
that's right just recently
i've not answered your questions
[Music]
why is it why is it shattering all this
why
[Music]
an issue that we were monitoring and in
some thing of our uh discussion in 1610
about when they were in the pool about
whose responsibility this was uh we've
had it's taken us a while to get to the
point of understanding what the issue is
and actually it turns out that all
orders didn't optimum time to do this
piece of work in terms of income
so there's a number of reasons to play
we couldn't have done it
it's probably straightforward so and
this and there's no point
i suppose what you're saying is that
what with lovely weather like this
people are using the pleasure facilities
less and it's a quieter time that makes
sense
as well
we gave it a lot of consideration over
when it would be the best time and it
might sound a bit strange but it's also
um summer holiday like people going like
men's stuff going on holiday as well
there's another thing um
[Music]
facility for many years on this council
i've always been told we leased it from
democracy
and this has been a new discovery after
what is now 15 years of being on the
council
can you tell me when we discovered
that it was no longer released but owned
and
what is the course implication is it
favorable to us or negative to us thank
you chair
i think um
station's gonna answer that one i think
it might have been my confusion i think
when we were
looking at leisure centers as a whole i
had it in my mind that we didn't own
holdworthy
um
there is some complicated arrangement
devon county originally licensed the
land to us and then we built the leisure
centre
um with a shared management agreement
with the school so there is a
complicated ownership there so if
there's any confusion it was probably
caused by me i'm very happy to put my
hand up to that and then when we started
reviewing the sites and reviewing what
we could do
and we delved down into all the detail
and it transpired that we did own
holsworthy but to be fair the council
didn't know because when i checked with
the finance team it was within our
insurance arrangements so if i had put
that message out there then i i can only
apologize
but only to say that before this point
it wasn't within our control because we
of course released it to 1610
with the previous leisure contract
that's the second part thank you for
your response assistant that's very good
thank you very much for that what is the
is there any course implications that is
going to impact into the future with
that
yeah well we've got an agreement with
dublin council council for access to
wholesome village center for the school
and that's the index link to inflation
and so you'll change to that arrangement
thank you very much
that's your question
yeah can i ask page 23 under income talk
about income is 98 000 pounds less than
the budget
but the leisure service manager
predicting a growth of income
may need to increase swimming lessons i
mean what's that based on and i have to
say i'm not sure if they're interested
the british trust you actually pay fifty
thousand pounds every year to more
swimming lessons
so i can't see where the increase is
coming from
chair up from that thing
so so yeah the uh head of leisure
operations matt he's been doing a lot of
work on where there's growth potential
for us as a business of tutorials
um swimming lessons is a growth market
there's a latent uh demand for swimming
lessons out there there's not enough
supply
and he believes he can grow that he also
believes there's some flexibility in how
much you can charge for that so i think
from memory i think it was 21 pounds and
uh for a set for a set of sessions he uh
believes quite confidently we can push
that to 25 to 26 pounds actually
tourists will implement that that
generates more income that still makes
us about two or three pounds more
affordable than other similar providers
[Music]
and good feedback for local people um
they're really glad to have it back and
it's been
a swimming lessons
what was that counseling
so
we're listening good
and the swimming lessons as well like
shawn is saying our young people haven't
been able to have some lessons
for two years so there is that demand
for it and children need to be able to
learn to swim and they've been missing
out on that and some of the other
providers the charges are quite
considerable and a lot of people can't
actually afford it whereas active
storage is quite affordable for prices i
know the bridge trust put in 50 000
pounds but that doesn't reach torrington
unfortunately
thank you very much for that everyone
well you know we don't need to vote on
that this is manchester united
[Music]
over the question
again thank you uh
i have actually had two emojis this time
uh one there is that is the second uh
leg of the damien chris uh this evening
uh the second is that uh
last week when the agenda went out
it did not contain the appendix
documents um for this cultural strategy
which uh
contained some of the background
information
and provides a lot of the
case studies since i wanted to write a
little bit of information about that in
this
presentation um that i confess
[Music]
last week
early in the year was announced as a
parts council of england leveling up
cultural priority um however in this
scenario this is a slightly strange one
because
we
had not been announced by the advanced
council
themselves as one of their cultural
properties so the arts council are
currently running
two separate priority strategies
and the north devon has been listed as
both priorities
and they have been receiving significant
supports from the arts council uh over
the last couple of months and we however
are only a lending up cultural priority
um which integrates more closely with
the government for
germany um
however in order for us to be able to
access any future funding
from the arts council and to strengthen
the um budgeting opportunities of
cultural organizations within torridge
and the arts council has made it very
clear that they require us to have a
cultural strategy in place
to justify why finances are being
requested
[Music]
at the moment i believe that there are
two um
national portfolio organizations
operating in torridge um boosters and
libraries and i believe that uh
the cloud arts center is now in the
process of also
[Music]
[Music]
the arts and creative industries
do have a significant
both
monetary and well-being impact
on the area
however it's also a crucial as a
reference to kind of show those
varieties and a crucial element to be
attracting business investment into the
area when we look
again
without the king maritime
innovation center um to make sure that
we are actually seen truly as a great
place to live as well as work as well
[Music]
in terms of our goals for uh strategy
and
it might surprise you to know that i am
not a cultural officer uh i think you've
seen me with various different hats on
especially during the last three weeks
um so we did have to rely on the
baseline consultants and wider and
stakeholders uh in the area including
the range of cultural organizations uh
present here in the area
um
but the very crucial thing was to
establish a vision for culture that was
not exclusive
that's when you speak to different
people in northern devon and doctors in
particular actually what does culture
mean for them
that means a lot of different things
for some people that culture could be
around surf culture it could be around
music culture it could be around parks
it could be iran's theater it bears
castle hudson central new york
um which i hardly agree with it could be
just um
being involved in the village pantomime
in one form
it's
of
various different forms of culture that
bring people together to strengthen
communities and that make place a better
place to be part of let alone to live
within
and
when you're going to start layering kind
of bond there are opportunities
to use culture and creative industries
in particular
creating industries example of a
non-place banned
industry
don't think it's um much taught everyone
is around the opportunities of people
not being case specific when you look at
the uh inspirational opportunities that
we know are very much the case uh here
in turish it's how we can then put the
infrastructure in place and supports in
place for those industries to thrive
moving forward
however
[Music]
to encompass all of those points in one
document is a virtually impossible task
um
which would ultimately lead to a
document that was completely unwieldy
and undeniable
it's not just about having something
written down but it's actually about
them
taking action towards creating change
and absorbing
um
if we're attempting to capture
absolutely everything that i just
mentioned within one strategy document
you inevitably set this over to fail
um so i apologize there will be uh
everyone across the room when we have
evidence so if shoot will be
[Music]
but
what we did was try and make sure that
we created a document that could be
delivered and also crucially that fits
within the arts council's requirements
given that they are the main culture
culture and cultural funder in the
country
[Music]
uh in terms of the appendix documents um
which again i apologize
[Music]
and there are a number of different uh
more detailed elements that
that
um i think the crucial thing uh is the
contents list
and that the advantage provides more
detail in terms of uh the fullness of
people and organizations who have
consulted and
various different statistics around the
cultural sector
and that says next language
however
that
this list of different
awards is really rather telling in terms
of the volume of what can officially be
classified as culture
that takes place in the entire entire
moment
when you look at the water being least
likely to be accessing
arts and culture
they do sadly feature very heavily as
always within touch
and then when on flip side when you look
over at the list of locations that are
likely to be accessing arts and culture
at the moment sadly those focused by now
they're from the new zealand council
only
now again what that doesn't do is take
into consideration the sense of
those wider elements of what we might
call culture
we can't catch up on figures around uh
development
for example we can't necessarily capture
kind of how many people go for open mic
[Music]
funders in australia to secure that
funding
and again when you look at the man of uh
[Music]
official cultural activity that's taking
place and across the region
you can see that again exactly we've got
the next grade
sorry
sorry next level is
i'll get to that
um
sadly again that map does very much lead
towards
the vast majority of kinds of
the activity taking place in north devon
and that's where the jobs are that's
where
uh
leaning towards
that next
mechanism i won't go through these next
three slides
in detail because they're contained in
the report
but
the culture strategy does rely on three
key themes um which as you will see
[Music]
the rather lengthy kind of strategy um
do you have very much a tie to kind of
nature
and there's a sense of heritage within
um
[Music]
[Music]
yes
um which leads down to cultural
development funds and again this is a
part of the frustration about this
process uh and also around the fact that
all of these funding streams have
completely aligned um
[Music]
form we were delighted to hear when live
and slide in which was a massive relief
activity that's been taking place over
the last couple weeks
um we then have the shared prosperity
funds that has to be submitted across
the first of august
um and we have the cultural development
plan where we have to submit some
expression of interest and by the 29th
of july
and so with small authorities such as
ours to enlighten all these different
streams really make sure that those um
[Music]
it's
given uh previous updates given to
the council around the fact that if it
is currently the most economically
vulnerable uh town in devon
which is laid onto the regeneration
board
and
we also know that animal rights by next
june uh june 23 uh bit of the library
will become uh
vacant
uh again and will become uh the
responsibility for executive
[Music]
[Music]
kick start um process energy security
um unfortunately without that goal
strategy to get in place we will be able
to justify kind of
seeking values of past council
funds
at the same time
going back to uh
raised around the importance of
overwhelming education
[Music]
disrespectful projects and supporting uh
educational growth
amazing
uh
creating opportunities for young people
to be coming through and to be inspired
um i think that
social mobility and aspiration and
creating that sense of vibrancy to
provide opportunities for young people
to stay within our local economy and
then our local community has to be a
crucial thing that we will be rushing as
part of culture as well and trump's
submission
[Music]
missed all the pictures of bristol
it was in portugal and southeast asia a
bit about the library i'm sorry to be so
parochial after that but on page 31 of
our agenda tonight
it says as part of that expression of
interest process a simple feasibility
study for the future of bitter library
should be undertaken
now devon county when we started
developing the new library so this is
really quite impressive but then goes on
to say an initial architectural concepts
to be developed
and yet
i've on the town council i did ask all
the other councillors what they would
like to see there and there's a whole
range of ideas which would need a lot of
different architectural
uh concepts so go ask are we
are you jumping the gun here
to a certain extent yes for this uh the
fact that kind of what we need to be
looking at is
especially saying in this expression of
interest this is what we will spend the
next six uh
four or five months building up to if we
are allowed to go into a full
application process in november um
when i say different library pages what
i should say is the carnegie library
building
um because the
works on new
business library in the arts center
building are really effectively kind of
the way
i have no desire to create a vital
library uh facility within uh
within the community building and what
we do need to do is exactly as you say
can security build on those
opportunities and suggestions and mesh
that with genuine community need
an opportunity
whilst
cynically
making sure that what we
put forward
is a
building proposal
that can
indeed pay its way
because again it's been referenced that
the finance is not there for tourists to
do to
financially support projects so that's
where this detailed feasibility in the
interim period will need to take place
that feasibility
working with a range of absolutely sort
of key stakeholders we need to be
accompanied by um architectural
uh sort of works because otherwise we
don't
actually learn how to actually if some
of the concepts will be able to work
uneasy
um
seeing neglect of torrington really
figures it's very low participation
culture
especially
it's always surprisingly given the cloud
that
it was not an easy uh thing to type when
writing um
this sort of recommendation
um
i came back to council letters earlier
about um
trying to do too much um
what a funny biz we need to do is to
really put together a strong narrative
to justify kind of
not only what we want to do with money
but also
cynically speaking the funders wanted to
come out of uh
the process
with learning about how their funding
has
impacted
and so you need to sell them kind of a
story that's different from the ones
that they've been
investing before
the difficulty in going out for
district-wide
which is discouraged by the arts council
is that you start
almost
having difficulties and saying no
so if we're going to do this benefits
and and absolutely if we're doing
something
then we actually need to do something
pose already and how can we do something
in three main towns without them doing
something in kind of rural areas and
all of a sudden you have uh
portmanteau
proposal that actually doesn't have that
strong
thread
which is clear to understand
chris thank you for your report
um
it is the challenges you got uh this is
under an overview to culture in northern
devon they're in the bottom of the page
and it's page 42 i think
you've got community fragmentation
uh a rise in retirees and second
homeowners has altered community
dynamics
does the policy seek to bring
home owners and retirees together
because i can think of certain streets
and areas where there'd be a row if
money is spent on improving things for
second homeowners when some of the
indigenous young people are struggling
to get their first home down here i just
wonder what the driver was between that
challenge and what you're meaning and
what you're aiming to do with that
challenge
um
[Music]
the good thing about culture is that it
is to a certain extent
it does not check kind of the status of
your payments
um but what we absolutely do need to do
is that any funding that is secured
is then utilized exactly as you said to
creating the right kinds of
opportunities what we don't do is
effectively create and
subsidize cultural opportunities
that are then not benefiting
the people who
go back to that uh earlier slide around
because they're low access to culture
we need
to use any funding we can secure
to have the right impact and make
people's lives better and then the world
being associated with that as well then
job creation and job improvement
opportunities
okay
yeah i just think it's a
great thing that you're doing here and
you know in my ward i mean it's
surprising what cultural things go on i
mean in harlem we've got an abbey and
they they are
you know foreign exhibitions that i mean
you've got many micro businesses potters
and uh artists alike and that you know
let their studios open so that's that's
for it all the time and you know they've
been there a long time they've been
still thriving at the belly you've got
the parents that they're they're
building up their business with the
their art and of course you've always
got the shoes that
are being put on
um
there seems to be a desert in our area
but yeah it's very important you know
there's a business into valley uh and
an ex-chancellor that is forever doing
film groups and things like that so you
know it is
something that is important
special language
the same way as the leisure centres so
post-pandemic is so important
um
schools etc can't work in isolation
doing the cultural side things it's got
to be embedded in the community it's got
to be in the community and you can
everybody together and it's so needed
desperately so so i just think this is
really important
yeah i was just going to say
i think we will approve all three
recommendations on page 34 so i
recommend
[Music]
well i i did speak when this crossed up
the weekend
i think i said well over the line
washington i think it is about my
question i've never seen such a
long-winded report in my life
i don't think the authors of it were
certainly
sometimes there's nothing else anyway
there's no mention of it
so i don't mean to put this together but
i'm not just gonna have to see from the
council built down council and torridge
as well as supporting money from
[Music]
you know
i like to support things that look like
they're going to be successful this is
just
you know
absolutely
thank you
[Music]
guys okay let's know the speakers we've
had a proposal from council lock but all
three of the recommendations are
accepted
and i think country jones had a sign up
first of all all those in favor please
all right and again
[Music]
thank you much clearly
thank you thank you
okay 13 there are no notices of motion
so that brings us to the
end